it is scorching Relentless devouring
everything in its path for the second
day the lava continued on its
destructive path in the ranis peninsula
sparing nothing it tore through the town
of grindvik setting houses Al light
spewing Ash and smoke through the air as
it burnt through pipes carrying water
and energy to homes the worst case
scenario that officials had feared for
despite months of preparation this could
be happening again and again for next
next years we don't know nothing about
it the uh Mother Nature is
unpredictable this is the second time
since November that residents were
forced to flee from their homes after an
earlier eruption giant fissures appeared
in and around grindvik a Telltale sign
of intense seismic activity but the lava
flowed in a different direction then
avoiding the town and till Sunday's
eruption this is as close as we can get
to the town itself the lava there is
continuing to smoke and erupt and of
course the
3,800 residents who've made this place
their home have no idea when they'll be
able to return
here the lava flows could continue here
for months and the intense seismic
activity could go on for years leaving
those who called this place home
stranded with no way of knowing if they
can return Sonia Gago Al jazer grindvik
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz